FORCING HUNDREDS OF  SIXTH WEEKS
PE THEIR HOMES.
COTO A N
THE UNITED MBEENPLACED IDAN.HAD
TH TO CHAD
OUR CNN CORRESNDA REPORTFO
ONLY SEE ON
>>or KIDS CR
CONSTANTLY.
THADULTS LOOK WEAROF WAR
THE PA HERE ARA
REMINDERF HOTHAT
DROVE UT O
S
KSERYONE.
AS FIGHTING INTENSIFIES IN
UR REGION,
SHE LEHAT HER N OR RISK GETTG
SON GOT  ITHCHS.BROTHER ISLLK T.
WASURED.
I  TMEO CHAD RCK
THE ONLY REASOI BACK  TIN AY
BROTHER HERE.
THERHAUCH  TOO LONG.
>> Reporter: BECAUSE OF DES
OF CONFLICT IN SMANY OF
SHE IS 22  KNOWN A READY BEEN LL
PERMANENT HOME F MLIFE.
WORRIED ABOUT
ALL THE LEFT BEHIND,Y , WHCOT C
GE
>>E THATOSN D CHILDREN HERWHAN?
>> Translator: THE MEN TOLD US
TOCHILDREN AND CROSS O THEY CAN.
>> Reporter: THE U.NE
AGENCY SAYS CLOSE TO 90% O
VAADM SUDAN AR
WIEEAL. RAUMATIZED TH
>> WE HA
REFUGEES A ARRIVED IN A
BORDER TN SS FROM SUDAN.
T JUST BEFORE WE ARRIV
WAS HIT
RO TO GEES ARE BNG
N TRAVELLED WITH SAMANTH E CHADN
THE WASS SUDAN AND IN ERION PEOC
NEIGHBCOUNTRIES.
>> WE MEE WOE EYE
HASICALLSOT ATTACKING HER.
ANISEEKING MEDICAL CARE  IN CHA.
V >> Reporter: IT'S A FUL
CIRCLE MOMENE G ABOUT CIVILIANEI
KNIVES AND MACHETES, KILLING E
>> Repor
HERE, HEH
YOU HEARTH0 YEARO AS A>> WELL,
AID, A BIG HUMANITARIAAGENCY.TA,
INSTITUTE FOR TH CAUSE
GETTING DRE TWO
THE INREOF PWHEEINSOR GRABS ASIU
THE FIFTH TIME IN THEIR LIS.
>> Reporter: CON
>> WE EDECTIVEK ST
WITH ALL THE SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNMENT OF CHA THAT RD
>> Reporter:SE ARE THE
INNOCENT VTIAD LEN THE POOR AND
QUICKLY SPILLED OVERO
REGIONAL REFUGEE CRIES STAHE
MOSTLY ISUDAN, BUTR CED,
200,000 NTO IGIE EGYPT
AD.GEES ARE IN EASTERN
CHAD DON'T LIV .
DEGREEFAHRENHEIT.
STCTT IN MAKESHIFT
REIT S FOR THEM THANN
DARFUR WHERE THEHA.
TIN D, SOMES
AND THEY DON'T CARH OF THE
TWO RRS.
EYEA